thank you very much thank you everyone
for coming I think a few of you have
seen some sort of some other
presentation of this talk so feel free
to leave this is about dynamic matching
market design a joint watch with two
wonderful quattro changu Lee who is
sitting there and show your Novus Quran
who is at University of Washington so
let's start for this audience I have I
don't have to actually prove that
matching markets are important they
surround us kidney exchange school
choice labor markets national residency
matching program of course dating
markets these are all matching markets
in which not only you have to choose
what also you have to be chosen and
prices do not do all the voyage I mean
these are important markets so computer
scientists and economists have spent a
huge amount of time starting from Gale
Shapley 1962 to analyze these markets
I'm not going to go through all these
papers what I want to emphasize is that
if you look at these papers you can see
that the question that is asking those
papers have the following theme given a
set of agents and their reported
preferences find a matching algorithm
with some desirable properties stability
efficiency or a strategy proof pneus
take the classic example of this
literature gave sharply I have an men
and women and my goal is to find a
stable match and the only question I
have to answer in order to find a stable
matching this environment is which
agents to match if I match this man to
that woman and that meant to this moment
the matching is going to be a stable and
the key point about this environment is
that once the match is made all is done
this is a great way to model school
choice or national residency matching
program that's exactly what you are now
doing in and RNP or New York City but
once you think about these are there
examples that I have here you can see
that this assumption that the set of
agents is given is too much of an
assumption for such environments in
these markets agents arrive as they and
depart continuously over time and the
composition of options at each point in
time is a function of the matching
algorithm if I do not match these two
agents today
they might be in the market tomorrow so
I can use them for some other form of
matching and because of this endogenous
feature in designing a matching
algorithm for these environments which
is the key goal of this paper we face a
dynamic decision problem rather than a
static decision problem in which in
addition to this classic question of
which agents to match we have to answer
the second question and that's the
question of vente match agents that's
the question of timing and this is the
focus of this paper in this talk so to
see why this is important I want to use
an example from kidney exchange you can
generalize it to some other markets
easily or with some tweaks but for those
of you who are not familiar with kidney
exchange a 30-second description of
what's going on in kidney exchange I
have kidney failure my sister is willing
to donate my kidney that's great but we
have to be blood type and tissue type
compatible tissue is a bunch of
different protein levels that I can
measure and tell you whether the
antibodies of my body are going to react
to the antigen of my sister if you pick
two random people from the US population
the chance that one of them can donate a
kidney to the other one is pretty loads
of the order of ten percent so it's
likely that my sister cannot donate a
kidney to me that's the bad news the
good news is that there might be some
other pair with the exact same problem
and the donor of that firkin donate a
kidney to me my sister can donate to get
into that patient we can have a kidney
exchange and this is how i'm going to
show this phenomenon in a graph each
node in this graph is a patient donor
pair it's important so each node is a
patient on a pair and each edge in this
graph shows I mean shows shows the
possibility of a kidney exchange now
let's let's see why I mean timing is an
important question and why we have to
think about timing and information in
these environments suppose I'm a market
major and I have the following graph I
mean I have patient on lepers 1 2 and 3
1 can be matched to 22 can be matched to
three in a static environment which is
the focus of literature so far or at
least until a couple of years ago if you
ask what is the optimal decision I mean
match one to two or two to three you
will
two people suppose I match one to two
they leave the market now it might be
the case that in a dynamic environment
tomorrow patient donor / 4 comes to the
market and because of all those
biological complexities 4chan only have
a kidney exchange with one in which case
the optimal decision is to match 1 to 4
and 2 to 3 and I cannot do that if I do
not wait in the first period so
information about future trade
opportunities is going to be important
now there is a second type of
information that can help me in such
environments and that's why waiting can
be valuable suppose I mean in the same
scenario I match one to two they leave
the market now in the next period I get
some signal that this patient donor pair
3 is in urgent need now if I do not
match one to two in the first period i
can save 3 by matching 322 but in this
in this environment that I've matched
1222 has already left the market I
cannot match them so information about
agents urgency of needs you can
generalize it to information about
agents waiting costs is going is going
to be an important information now the
questions I'm going to ask in this talk
or at least in the paper maybe we don't
get through all of them in this talk or
maybe these examples that I showed you
or just some toy examples may be waiting
is not as valuable as we saw so the
first question is can you quantify this
option value of waiting and then if
waiting is costly what is the optimal
waiting cost what kind of information
can help us to make the right timing
decision and if that information is a
private information of the agents can
you design a mechanism to extract that
information from agents see why this
question might be important in practice
if you look at different kidney exchange
pools all around the world you can see
that the Alliance for paired donation
the biggest kidney exchange pool in the
United States they conduct a maximum
matching algorithm every day so they
wake up every morning they look at their
pool and they find a maximum matching
every day of course they have some
maximum rated matching algorithm but the
point is that they do that
every day the United Network for Organ
Sharing does the exact same thing every
week every Monday South Korea every
month netherland a recorder I'm not
saying all of them are right or all of
them are wrong maybe there is a
fundamental difference in all these
markets but the point is that these
policy measures are actively choose are
actually thinking about timing in
addition to matching and the goal of
this paper is to construct a model by
which we can think about the optimal
timing decision in systematically what
we are going to find let me tell you the
let me spoil the results the main result
is going to be that this this option
value of waiting or the upper bound up
on the option value of waiting when
waiting cost is zero is going to be huge
so it's not going to be something as
small if you'll see it's going to be
exponentially valuable and the reason
that it's going to be valuable is
actually very intuitive the reason is
that while waiting I'm going to thicken
the market I'm going to keep options
often open i'm going to have a thick
market and then whenever i get this
signal that someone is urgent i have to
match that that agent with high
probability i can save that agent and we
are going to see that this is going to
be an exponential effect now the second
point is that as we saw here this piece
of information was crucial in this
result and we are going to see that if
you do not observe when agents need is
about to expire when agents are going to
depart then we chance to then then
thickness is going is not going to help
us and that piece of information is
going to be extremely important and the
reason is that I can be if I have that
information I can be patient with
respect to others and only serve those
people who are going to have very high
waiting costs and in some environments
including kidney exchange that
information might be a private
information of the agents or the doctors
or the hospitals because kidney exchange
rules are different entities from
doctors and hospitals we are going to
think about some ways to extract that
information in a truthful way
so the least review let me just skip
this is the static literature review
there are some papers on the dynamics of
matching markets we have Nick sitting
here and let me describe the model for
you and then we can come back and think
about the differences of different
papers with this paper or please remind
me if there is something which is not
here in the paper you talk about urgency
maybe also the different matches have
different weights or values yeah the
same role that's something I get
something so match that would be really
really valuable that's not necessarily
urgent that's a similar role would that
be different oh that would be different
in the sense that if I have a very
valuable match but these two people have
very small waiting costs then I'm not
going to match them until the point that
one of them becomes urgent then yeah
exactly so so so that's what that would
be that would be similar but that would
be a different model we will see so this
is a structure I probably don't get to
extension so I start with the setup of
the model i will tell you too many
results of the paper with a norm helping
me in time and then we will conclude so
let's start with the model
this is everything about the modern so
nothing more is about to come so if you
want to take your nap please do it in
after two minutes this is Lloyd is the
most important a slide of the talk
agents arrived to this market with an
exogenous postal rate em so in
expectation and new agents arrived to my
market and then each two agents are
going to have an acceptable transaction
there is going to be an edge between
these two these two agents with
probability P iid that's one
simplification compared to real world
because there are some correlations but
let's let's assume these these edges are
independently drawn and then there is an
exponential clock which takes with rate
one that's just normalization each agent
is connected to an exponential clock and
whenever that clock ticks that agent
becomes critical this is a very stylized
way for me to model the fact that we
have a very short horizon but accurate
information about agents departure time
in the paper we are going to relax this
assumption in both direction what if you
know far ahead of time that someone is
going to be critical what if you don't
observe agents who are critical and we
are going to see that this information
is going to be very important so
whenever an agent becomes critical
that's the last point in time that the
planet can match that agent so an agent
leaves in one of the following two ways
you become critical then you leave the
market either master on match or you get
matched and you leave the market
seems to me as local kidney exchange the
critical is a little enforceable i can
imagine patients gradually go downhill
maybe there's a sharp drop in fact you
really don't want to wait till the high
rear so I have a show you a graph
perhaps after this but in kidney
exchange you you usually start by being
informed that you are going to have a
kidney failure in six months then you
have basically very low waiting costs up
to that point then you start dialysis
you have a small waiting cost during
dialysis during the first months of
dialysis then there is some points that
actually Sosa waiting cost is in some
sense convex there is some point in
which you you actually have a very high
disk utility because of some biological
issues that I don't want to get into but
you're right so there so I'm just
assuming that waiting cost is zero and
suddenly jumps but basically you have
some small decay and then that's true
in criticality is observed so you don't
need to incentivize an agent to reveal
when they're critical depends on how you
define the criticality so yes I mean a
kidney exchange put basically can can
put some monitoring devices they don't
do it now so they don't follow the
health condition of patients but that's
one way to observe this information in
which case you don't have any incentive
ish but then you have to have some
monitoring infrastructure and so on
rather than asking hospitals like public
information common road knowledge no so
so so that the structure of the network
is known only to the market maker known
to the market maker but not to the not
to the age of any private information
that's a disarming parameter so me as a
market designer I can actually design it
but currently no they don't observe
because if they observe them they don't
have any incentive to come to the pool
they can just go to a doctor and ask him
to match them that's the reason that
they come to the market so this is how
the system works just just I mean you
calm you you make some random matches
then someone gets critically cannot
match them they leave I mean some other
people come this guy gets critical I'm a
match them and then I match two agents
both of them are going to leave all
edges connected to them will disappear
from this network this is how the system
evolves so let me just tell you one more
parameter and then asked questions about
the answer questions about the model so
this model has two parameters MMP I want
to use only one bit of your memories so
i'm going to multiply n by P and ask you
to remember G these M times P why this
parameter is important because if the
planner is inactive if I do not match
any one agents come to the market is
rate m each agent leaves the market with
right one so the expected size of the
market is going to be M because in that
case arrival and departure are equal and
in a market of size M if I come to this
market there are M people here then I
have a P chance to be matched to
everyone d is going to be my expected
degree of course I mean a
room full of computer scientists this is
basically the erdos-renyi parameter this
is Howard usually define in there the
random graph by setting this p equal to
d / m and then d is going to be the
expected number of edges you are going
to have the point is that I can measure
d I can go to Alliance for paired
donation see what is M their arrival
rate which is 500 around five hundred
agents per year see what is P and then i
can calculate D in different kidney
exchange pool this number D is something
between three to ten so you can think
about it something like that but the
point is that we can we can actually go
and measure it so if there is any
questions about the modern yeah so it's
it's it's it's so it's an extremely
heterogeneous market because of tissue
type compatibility so the these protein
levels are continuous levels in that
sense it's not too far but yeah in
principle you have to consider different
types and with the very people are hard
to make I mean would they be captured by
this model or did it around so this
model is assuming everyone is ex ante
equal basically in keeping exchange if
you look at tissue type issue there are
two types of people hard to match and
easy to match so that's the second paper
that i'm not going to present today but
i'm writing with two two quarters and
they actually show that one of the
results of this paper will fail i will
tell you which one but the other one
will not
so that the planner observes yes I
believe you should be seen this boy I
like three way or change no yeah you are
abstracting to just focus on this
problem of timing versus matching in
this environment and that's a feature of
kidney exchange we try to make it a more
general setting in some sense to capture
other markets too but that's a that's a
good point another thing is that these
exchanges have been moving to shorter
time scales for the matching like they
started off maybe months two months and
you know started with monks here maybe
are going to tell us a they are making a
mistake and they should do something
different no I'm going to tell you that
they might be making a mistake but the
other point is that there is a platform
competition basically in us because
there are multiple platforms trying to
get more and more easy to match people
so it's not easy to say that they should
they should move into that direction
because they want but but I will tell
you that under some conditions you
actually want to be greedy but yeah so
yes I know so no wasn't there so the
planner observes this trade
possibilities graph at each point in
time the planner observed who is
critical and because this is a
continuous time model there is at most
one critical agent at each point in time
and the matching algorithm is a function
from this network and who is critical to
a matching a set of disjoint edges well
too short so and the goal of the planner
is to suppose waiting cost is zero for
now I want to find the upper bound on
the value of waiting then the goal of
the planner is to minimize the fraction
of agents who leave the market unmatched
I want to minimize the fraction of
agents who perish so this is a verifying
Markov decision problem I know the model
I know they're matching algorithm I know
the objective but as are all of you
probably know is it's it's each state of
this problem is a network and it's a
combinatorial complex
state-space I cannot use standard
bellman equations to solve this for the
optimum of this problem and in fact I
don't want to do that what I want to do
is to move from this complex optimum to
some simple matching algorithms because
I'm not fully agnostic about the optimum
solution of this problem I know one
thing about the optimum solution which
is that I do not match any agents unless
I mean I do not match any pair of agents
unless one of at least one of them is
critical so if I have two agents where
none of them is critical there is no
reason to match them waiting cost is
zero by assumption so it can wait up to
the point that someone gets critical I
also know that when someone gets
critical I definitely match that agent
because the best I can do by not
matching this critical agent and saving
someone else for future is to save
someone else in future so I match I
conduct I do a matching if and only if
someone is critical now to whom I
exactly match a critical agent that
depends on the network is structure so
that's the problem of matching the first
one is the problem of timing now I
designed to matching algorithms to
detach these two effects I start by a
greedy algorithm and mimic of the
Alliance for paired donation algorithm
whenever an agent arrives if that agent
has any acceptable transactions I choose
one of them uniformly a trend
and then I design a second matching
algorithm patient which has that optimal
timing feature of the optimum whenever
an agent becomes critical I look at that
agent if that agent has any acceptable
transactions I choose one of them
uniformly at random now it's clear that
this patient algorithm is choosing the
optimal time but it's pretty naive in
choosing the optimum agent suppose I
have this network and two is critical I
can match two to one in which case this
would be the remaining network I can
match two to three that would be the
remaining network clearly this is the
optimum choice patient is not even
chooses one of them uniformly at random
so what I'm going to do next is to
detach these two if these two effects in
the following way so I know that if this
this is my loss the minimum loss is zero
the loss of the greedy is under the
optimum is here and patient is somewhere
in between patient is better than the
greedy but it cannot be better than the
optimum this distance here is my gain
from optimal timing and this distance
here is my additional game from
optimizing over the network structure so
this is conceptually what I'm going to
quantify and remember be was the oh yeah
and that's the point I want to see
whether I'm in this world that most of
the gain is achieved by optimal matching
or I'm in this world that most of the
game is achieved by optimum timing
before this talk I'm going to focus on a
steady estates relatively large values
of DN M&D greater than to all of them
are carefully studied in the paper so
let's see the main result which is
actually what your said I'm going to
tell you that timing is important sure
now opt is the solution of that mark of
decision problem so I look at that fork
who is critical I choose the optimal
match so remember D was this network is
sparsity parameter something between two
three to ten in different kidney
exchange pools in USD is more than South
Korea because we have more patience this
is the main result that the main result
about timing that the loss of the greedy
algorithm is at least 1 / 2 D plus 1 and
the loss of the patient algorithm is
upper bounded by e to minus T over 2
divided by 2 and the last line is just
the combination of these two so if these
eight the loss of the patient is at most
seventeen percent of the loss of the
greedy algorithm
which is suggesting that when mating
cost is zero then the other the upper
bound on the value of a ting is huge now
the second piece of that graph that we
showed you the optimization part I don't
know how the optimum vorks I don't know
exactly how who is going to be matched
to home in optimum but I can bound the
performance of the optimum and we can
see that the loss of the patient which
was upper bounded by this number the
loss of the optimum is upper bounded by
this number which is a fractional
difference between those two but this is
just telling me that by moving from
patient to optimum I may I gained
something but it's not huge in fact if
we put some reasonable numbers we can
see that the loss of the greedy is
eight-point-five percent and the loss of
the patient is going to be 0 point nine
percent and the additional gain from
moving by moving from group from patient
to optimum is going to be much smaller
than the other one of course relatively
speaking it's not much as smaller I'm
talking about the additive difference
and so most of the gain in this model I
want to emphasize is achieved by merely
being patient one of the results which
phase if you have multiple types is this
second part so if you have hard to match
and easy to match people then this part
is going to be important as well but
this part remain is important thank
and this is just a this access is d
that's lost this blue one is the lower
bound on this is the best greedy can do
this is the optimum and this is divorce
patient is going to do so as d increases
patient actually gets closer and closer
to the optimum and in these areas of the
map patient has actually a a good good
distance from the optimal and that's
because the probability of observing
those are structures that I showed you
as an example is not actually very low
we see those examples patient is naive
but the reserve army so this is the this
is showing that the greed is somewhere
here this is that the lower bound on the
greedy and patient is here and Optus
here
so since I only have five minutes the
question is what should I do let me just
move from this part to this part and
tell you one more theorem which is about
the value of information so this is what
we saw patient greedy and 0 now I want
to relax this informational assumption
what if we know more what if you know
less so let's forget about what if you
know what if we know more because
whatever is that it's going to be here
we can see in the paper if you design an
omniscient algorithm which knows
everything the loss is going to be e 2
minus D so let's let's forget that for
now the point is that if I do not
observe this critical agents they become
critical and they leave the market
without informing me then the loss of
the best possible algorithm you can
design the solution of that mark of
decision problem is going to be very
very close to the loss of the greedy so
the best you can do without that
information is 1 over 2 D plus 1 and I
can show that actually the loss of the
greedy is upper bounded by log 2 divided
by D there is a conjecture this a movie
conjecture that actually greed is
optimum in this setting but we couldn't
prove it because that's that lower bound
is very very conservative so this is
actually showing that this criticality
information and market thickness are
compliments I do not wait to I do not
want to wait I don't want to wait too
thick in the market if I do not have
that information and if I have that
information and waiting cost is low then
I want to actually wait to seek in the
market and the way we get that lower
bound is actually in the following way
that I don't know how the optimum works
this this is my favorite proof of the
paper so let me spend two minutes to
present it but whatever is that optimum
it's going to have some expected pool
size some how many agents I have in the
pool whatever is that optimum now I know
that when I do not observe critical
agents the losses is the loss is going
to be how many agents are having the
pool times T why because each agent is
becoming critical
one so the perishing rate of the system
is exactly equal to the expected pool
size they become critical I don't
observe them they leave the market
unmatched and if I run the system from
time 0 to time chap t expected pool size
time cap t tell me how many agents are
going to leave the market unmatched so I
know that this is this is a lower bound
on how on the number of people who are
going to leave the market unmatched on
the other hand I can count the number of
agents who come to the market do not
have any acceptable transactions upon
arrival and do not have any acceptable
transactions during their sojourn in the
market as a function of the expected
full size and that's going to be a
decreasing function because if expected
pool sizes infinity everyone is going to
have at least one acceptable transaction
if expected pool size is zero no one is
going to have any acceptable
transactions so that's going to be a
decreasing function of the expected full
size for any algorithm and I know that
my loss is above these two graphs
because these are two lower bounds and
if i write down the closed form for this
one and intersected with this one the
best pool size i can have for any
algorithm is M over 2 D plus 1 so there
is no way that you can do better than
that if your pools are expected pool
size is less than that this is going to
be this is going to kill you and if the
pool size is more than that then the
number of people who actually become
critical and you don't observe them is
going to create some troubles if this is
the pool size then the loss is going to
be 1 over 2 plus 1
and I think I'm almost done with the
time so let me do not go through their
mechanism design part so i looked at the
timing of the talk it was twelve eleven
forty five to twelve fifteen i said oh i
have 45 minutes that was the that was
the proof that there are three types of
economists those who can count and those
who can't so please ask questions
so if that's probably exactly so that's
it so if that probability is not very
very close to one so if you observe them
we'd probably see ninety eighty percent
then you are still want to be greedy
because greedy is doing relatively well
so if you do not observe so in fact so
let me just finish by this slide which
is there are good reasons to be greedy
and one of them is that the Fei ting
cost is high so we actually characterize
the optimal waiting time as a function
of waiting cost in the paper and if you
don't have this piece of information or
if you have that piece of information
with relatively low probability if it's
ninety percent or less then you actually
do want to be greedy because greedy is
performing relatively well and if P is
very very small suppose P is zero so
nobody's matched to everyone the
ingredient and patient are basically the
same no one can be matched to anyone if
P is very very high one then greedy and
patient are basically the same we can
match everyone and in fact the relative
that the value of waiting is an inverse
you function of this parameter P so
there are good reasons to be greedy if
you are in such environments so let me
just conclude by by by this last slide I
that even the optimum algorithm cannot
match all agents as you've seen it's e
to minus T over 2 so drink more water to
prevent kidney failure that's the only
employee I mean practical policy advice
I can have for you
why market split it seemed that Oh in
pieces without where are the different
markets in the slide in the US yeah so
it's it's a very good question so there
are different people with different
objectives they have their own I mean
border border advisory and whatever but
I don't know why they don't that's also
a very good question and that's because
one reason is that your doctor
introduces you to these different kidney
exchange pools and if I as the doctor
introduce you to that kidney exchange
pool and they find a match then I'm
going to actually do the transplant so I
don't have incentive to introduce you to
everywhere but I honestly I ask actually
some doctors and why this is happening
that I mean ten percent of people
multiple register and no one knows
exactly what's going on okay multiplayer
with that lecture no it's it's fine i
mean you can do that yeah so yeah so he
did it that he did that actually but he
was in multiple cadaver kidney pools not
get in exchange but understand it's also
possible to do a three-way yeah which
head is this impact the rate effect oh
so there are so in a static setting
there are papers that show that moving
from two to three actually saves a lot
of I mean it's going to decrease the
death rate by a huge factor in that
dynamic environments I think there is a
paper by yasha and eat I and two other
quarters i don't remember more than two
names usually so so they actually show
that even in a dynamic environment
moving from two to three is a big jump
saving people let's take the risk of
flying